Quentin this is your eighth movie and
it's called the hateful eight is this a
happy accident or a grand design I don't
think it's quite a grand design but I
think it's a little bit more intentional
than a happy accidents all right I don't
think it was a situation where i
actually had seven characters or nine
characters but i decided to add another
one or get rid of another one just to
make it eight there's so many great
speeches that you get to deliver in this
film where would you say they rank on
some of the favorite speeches that
you've given on film don't know yet you
know I'm kind of not assessing them in
that way okay but I mean I know that a
pretty pretty um controversial yes I'll
say that yes they are huh and I'd say
poignant to that yes yeah yeah there's
so much great language in this script
words like molasses like instead of say
move slowly or bustering you know people
kill each other buster did you find
yourself adopting any of Quentin's great
language Quentin finds a style in that
and he takes that style and he mixes it
with spaghetti western any mixes it with
old old western that's really a blessing
so when you're gonna say molasses like
you go from reading and going oh Jesus
to loving it you know when you were in a
Quentin Tarantino movie you just give
yourself over you're in such good hands
you're in the like I just loved every
second it's not just that he brings it
every day but he insists that we bring
it every day he's very brave and he's
backed up by people who aren't brave the
producers of it you know they they allow
him to do what he does raise your hand
if you would say you enjoyed filming in
the snow oh oh yeah okay so it wasn't
cold and miserable even me even me being
a tropical fish I don't know even me no
I i end up every second of it I love
that when you work with like when you
know that that dude is going to capture
it in a way that is so far beyond your
imagination your eight actors who play
the hateful eight are in a room a fight
breaks out and it's every man for
himself which
the eight actors not characters makes it
out alive if cunning guile and wildness
is actually going to get you to the end
ah it's hard to put it's hard to say
that anybody's gonna be more cunning
guile or wily than samuel l jackson no
one said this job supposed to be easy
nobody says both be that neither